notre intestin ce deuxième cerveau où
vivent des dizaines de milliers de
milliards de micro organismes
aurait-il un lien avec certaines
maladies mentales s'il est difficile
d'arrêter aujourd'hui une réponse la
recherche avance joël doré a reçu le
prix marcel dassault 2017 pour son
projet sur le microbiote intestinal
chez les personnes avec trouble du
spectre de l'autisme
l'objet du projet est de mieux
documenter mieux caractériser la
relation entre le patient et son
microbiote dans le contexte de des
troubles du spectre de l'autisme avec
notamment un accent mis sur cette
relation altéré qui fait que plus de la
moitié des patients ont des symptômes
gastro-intestinaux pour tenter de
comprendre les relations entre les
bactéries présentes dans l'intestin et
les troubles de l'autisme deux cent
cinquante mille euros seront mises à
disposition du projet de joël doré une
manne financière qui pourrait à terme
améliorer la qualité de vie des patients
on met en oeuvre des outils qui sont les
plus performants aujourd'hui pour la
caractérisation du microbiote intestinal
et puis on va aussi inclure des patients
dont que 150 patients autiste asperger
50 individus contrôle qu'on va
caractériser de façon exhaustive à la
fois au plan clinique pour les patients
mais aussi au plan de la physiologie de
la nutrition du microbiote intestinal
bien sûr avec des outils qui sont
performants mais également cher les
troubles de l'autisme touche aujourd'hui
soixante mille personnes en france un
chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter alors
qu'il n'existe pour le moment aucun
traitement curatif